just a few weeks ago in the aftermath of
a nerve agent attack they targeted a
former Russian spy in the UK this is
practically all we heard from Democrats
and critics of President Trump listen
why on earth does Donald Trump not call
out the Russians they're attacking our
allies they're attacking our allies and
he's looking the other way that is a
disgrace it's max boot one of the
president's fiercest critics while the
president did this instead the Trump
administration is expelling 60 Russian
diplomats in response to the poisoning
of a former Russian double agent and his
daughter in England but that wasn't
enough Democrats have also been
relentless in making this demand Putin
will cooperate for two reasons one is
it's because it's in his interest or
because you you're taking tough actions
against him I going after the Oleg arcs
on whom he's so reliant which Trump
won't do someone was listening so what
President Trump do today we do have some
breaking news to bring you right now the
Trump administration is imposing new
sanctions on Russian oligarchs and
government officials no CNN but don't
expect to stop hearing this from the
president's critics there's still the
question of why President Trump has not
taken a more aggressive public stance
against Vladimir Putin the president has
not publicly said anything there are
always still questions so a president
Trump ever get credit for cracking down
harder on Russia than President Obama
ever did joining us now with reaction is
Stephen Cohen professor of Russian
Studies at New York University mr.
professor thank you for being here
appreciate it so I'll ask you that
question will this president ever get
credit for cracking down on Russia well
they keep telling him to get tougher and
they keep moving the goalposts and the
end zone is war
the critics you're saying his critics
are saying get tougher when he does get
tough this year that's not enough and
ultimately you're saying that if you
went that tough it leads us somewhere
well I mean if you want to ask me
whether Trump has been tougher than
Obama on Russia if we quantify it the
answer is probably yes he's expelled
more Democrat diplomats he's leveled
more saying you'd like to expel
Democrats if you could here's the
problem
you and I
you've got a family I'm guessin we're in
danger I would say the gravest danger in
regard to Russia since the Cuban Missile
Crisis we're in a new Cold War it's not
a joke it's much more dangerous than the
last wearing eyeball to eyeball military
confrontation Ukraine the Baltics
insurance sure
he sent weapons to Ukraine as well
something the Obama administration would
stop and think I'm older than you so I
remember this vividly throughout my
lifetime every american president
democrat or republican has been
empowered to deal with the leader in the
kremlin to keep us out of war and
prevent nuclear war maintain a
relationship right by the way the three
presidents who did that the most was
called d'etat when republicans
Eisenhower Nixon and Reagan Trump senses
were in grave danger with Russia there's
no question about it yeah he wants to
talk to Putin about international
terrorism and the new nuclear arms race
if he picks up the phone and calls and
says let's talk his critics here say
it's treason so well it's not funny I
mean not we're in danger and we've
always looked to the president I didn't
vote for trouble I opposed some of his
policies but his statement that it's
essential to cooperate with Russia is
the truth and every American should
support that and not attack him for
trying to do it because he's our safety
wall in between so you're saying you're
saying it's a smart move to be
professionally tougher but personally a
little bit more friendly we have to we
have to leave it right there
unfortunately in these moments you need
wisdom and and that's exactly what we'll
need to navigate this tough course
professor thank you very much for your
time appreciate it an expert on Russia